reject nation it is time for more koi's
comic corner i am very excited to be
joining you guys today we're going to be
talking about dc's upcoming slate but
first i want to remind you to leave a
like those help me out to keep this show
going also comment subscribe hit that
bell so you get notified of all these
shows coming at you and again thank you
for being so supportive of koi's comic
corner i am honored to be here let's
talk about dc slate now usually i give
you guys a breakdown of where we are
with dc or where we are with this comic
property or where the rumors are or what
comics to read etc that's what i like
this channel corner to be about but in
this case i want to go a little
different and just give you an onslaught
of information and then just give you
some general dc comic recommendations at
the end i'm going to give you 20
different movies in various stages of
development these are the top 20 either
in development fully made
post-production or rumored properties
coming out of dc films because i want to
see in a year or two which one of these
actually came to pass i think it's gonna
be really interesting with all of the
shake-ups over at dc because of the big
big discovery merger a lot of the big
higher-ups are getting shaken up a lot
of the movies that were almost happening
have been canceled a lot of things might
get green lit but i think it'll be
really interesting to look back at this
video in a year or two and see what
actually came to pass some of these we
obviously know are coming out obviously
black adam etc we'll get into that but
first let's dive into the giant slate of
maybe movies over at dc first one i want
to talk about just got confirmed with a
title that is joker 2 volley
i'm not french even though my last name
is i'm sorry to every french-speaking
person for that pronunciation this means
the madness of two joker to the madness
of two i think that it's gonna be really
cool to play with the mythology outside
of the world of batman some more because
we saw a young bruce wayne in joker i
never personally my opinion want to see
joaquin's joker go up against a batman i
think it's much more interesting to have
that lived separately i personally want
robert pattinson to have his barry keon
i want to see other batmans have their
jokers but i like joaquin phoenix's
joker being over there having an else
world living in that world hey guys
koi's out of town otherwise i'd have him
do the pickup here himself but he
actually did a joker video talking about
the whole lady gaga casting here that's
going to be a musical we shot this
before
that news broke but yeah cut out a lot
of other stuff he was speculated on here
but you can go check that one out we got
the flash movie up next i don't think a
movie has ever had more of a struggle
with a single individual
ever i mean there are obviously people
that mess up in life and they're
obviously asterixes and yes things have
been more problematic there are
directors that have done horrible things
they're actors that have done horrible
things there are people that are bad but
i don't know if the consistency has been
hit i know it must be a struggle for the
fine folks at wb to be navigating the
news cycles and i really hope ezra
miller can navigate what he's going
through i really hope that they find
what peace they can when they can that
said it's been like a monthly news cycle
situation so i don't know what dc and
warner brothers can do with the flash
because by the time it comes out we keep
hearing more and more things we keep
hearing rumors that the maybe adding in
a post-credits scene maybe recasting via
flashpoint it is very expensive to
recast it is very tricky to this late in
the game change things and i personally
i don't know ezra i want ezra to find
what solace he can and and clearly
there's some lashing out happening so
for the sake of the film i'm very
excited to see michael keaton back as
batman i'm very excited to see
flashpoint i'm very excited for the
surprises i'm very excited as a batfleck
fan to get to say bye to batfleck i love
ben affleck's portrayal as batman i
really truly i'll take any frame of flex
batman in a movie so i'm excited for
this film but on the more human real
elements i don't know how they're going
to promote it i don't know how they're
going to end it i don't know how they're
going to continue that story on and i
want the human that is ezra to get the
help they need and i want the studio
that is warner brothers to find a
compromise to have this movie come out
because i really want to see it we'll
see what happens in between there next
up we've got blue beetle this is really
high on my list because it looks
incredible from leaked photos i do not
talk about paparazzi photos it's a rule
of mine i do not believe in them because
frankly seeing an unfit it's like you go
into a a museum and there's a pencil
drawing that's not fair to compare to
this beautiful lush monet a finished
product is what you should experience
that is presented to you if you see a
leaked shot of a costume usually it
needs the augmentation of
post-production usually it needs a
little zhu xin up with some cgi because
comics aren't real i know for me to say
that is sacrilege but rarely do i see a
comic book costume that looks like it
was ripped off the page in a paparazzi
photo leaked image as the blue beetle
suit came out and i am gobsmacked this
looks incredible i've seen nothing
official and i am so overjoyed at how
incredible it looks and homeboy from
karate kid is awesome so the casting's
great the look is great blue beetle's a
really fun character hope we get a
little booster gold action i think zac
efron might be a little old for human
torch at this point depending on how
young they go because he's friends of
tomahawk spider-man i digress he'd be a
great booster gold give me zac efron's
booster gold in the blue beetle movie
even as a cameo very excited for blue
beetle and very quickly blue beetle is a
very
industrious for hire at times superhero
that's often down on his luck that
navigates the world opposite booster
gold who is a very very social media
inherent uh superhero so blue beetle's
got money booster gold needs attention
and they team up very often the comics
offering a very different dynamic duo
situation so booster gold is not
confirmed but it's kind of like if you
make a robin movie you expect batman not
to belittle blue beetle but they they
kind of go together all right next up
we've got aquaman and the lost kingdom
this is high because i don't know how
you make a sequel to a movie with an
octopus playing drums i don't know how
you go crazier and inherently sequels
get crazier inherently you have
escalation i personally like the aquaman
movie i got it made a billion dollars so
a lot of other people did too is it the
comics absolutely not is it a blast
absolutely do i want a sequel yes what
is it i don't know will it have amber
herd in it maybe but i am however
getting reports in my lack of earbud ear
they did talk about it at the trial at
some point and now walter hamada did say
it was a buddy movie between patrick
wilson and jason momoa and that's about
the main headline i got out of that
craziness so we do have a little bit of
taste and tone of what that movie's
gonna be and you guys know i love a
buddy movie so aquaman is a buddy movie
give me that all right next up we've got
black adam this is a movie i think
that's gonna combine the strengths of
the rox properties and the strengths of
dc universe's scope i do think that it's
going to be a very rock centric movie we
just got the first trailer it looks like
a rock movie there's a certain kind of
humor and action and levity the rock
brings to his properties we know how
hands on he is we know that seven bucks
productions is very very much a part of
the script a part of the edit a part of
the whole journey so i think we're gonna
see the most rock movie possible within
the dc universe and that's gonna be
interesting because i think dc is doing
a very good job at diversifying their
content i think a shared universe works
and it doesn't have to i like the marvel
cinematic universe but there are times
that i imagine people are exhausted them
like i have to watch a six-hour show
i've got to watch a three-hour movie you
don't have to do that with dc you can
just watch these movies so i think it's
really important especially with black
adam that people that are fans of the
rock don't necessarily have to watch
everything dc's doing i think that
people that are fans of the dc universe
they don't have to watch every single
property coming out it's a win-win i
think this movie is going to make a lot
of money i think the rock is dedicated
he 11 years in pre-production hell
really excited for this one if only
because of the sheer zeal coming out of
the rock we'll see what it actually
translates to and that's coming up soon
that was your top five i realize i've
already talked way too long so we're
gonna speed up here with six through
twenty number six we got shazam fury of
the gods this is coming out very soon it
is a sequel to the first shazam i think
my favorite dc property of all i love
that first movie this is gonna have the
kids growing up we actually have mary
marvel being herself as both iterations
of marvel so clearly aging is an element
and i love the tone the amblin toad that
david f sandberg was able to accomplish
can't wait to see the sequel then we've
also got the superman reboot coming from
jj abrams now this is interesting
because i've heard we're getting a
valzod series from michael b jordan and
it's rumored that we're gonna have a
black clark kent in this superman reboot
so i'm curious to see which these
properties comes out first how they
might interact with each other i know
that jj is not directing it i believe
it's uh not tom hassie coates that's
gonna be handling the directing duties i
love jj as a producer i'm really curious
especially because he was attached to a
superman flyby property that was
supposed to come out way before the
brandon rothman did so i know he loves
superman excited for that property and
to see how it develops we've also got a
batgirl property which is going to be
originally set for hbo max that is now
going to theaters there was so much
uproar about it being an hbo max release
that it actually got bumped up to a
theatrical release more of that i love
my theatrical releases and i love the
character of batgirl very curious to see
barbara gordon and we do have jk simmons
reprising his role as commissioner
gordon which means it is somewhat tied
into the universe but it does come out
after flashpoint just like we had the
great jk simmons has j jonah jameson in
no way home he seemed to be a different
jj jameson in no way home than the
original we might have that with
commissioner gordon but we also have the
little fact that michael keaton is in
this as well does it tie into the tim
burton universe post flashpoint is it a
batman beyond kind of vibe where he is a
mentor very curious to see how this
translates really excited for this
batgirl movie we've also got wonder
woman three this is presumably from
patty jenkins i am a giant giant
proponent for the first one it's my
number two dc property i think after
shazam right before the suicide squad
huge wonder woman fan i really want them
to get back in that like beautiful
magical overwhelming scope of the first
and i think they will i think dc smart
they're going to take some notes about
what didn't work in the second and give
us a huge third and at number 10 we've
got the batman 2. this is something i
want to do an entire video about so if
you're a fan of koi's comic corner let
me know that's something you want to see
i've got an idea of what the entire
trilogy yes the batman 3 is rumored how
i would shape it what i would do but as
of now we are confirmed for a the batman
2 i think it might be mr freeze i think
it also might have some setup for the
court of owls which ends up being the
third movie but again i'm gonna make a
whole video about that we've also got
zatanna this is the one that i'm most
worried about that i'm also most excited
for so if those top 10 were my most
anticipated this is the one where i'm
like all right now we're getting into
the does this exist territory which is
fitting for the second half of this list
zatanna is a magician she is awesome she
has magic powers technically she can
take out superman because homeboy can't
handle magic she's a very interesting
character she's got a really iconic look
and she's often written incredibly fun
she's very very captivating and often a
member of the dark justice league so
please have zaton exist i want it my
next most anticipated in the i don't
know if it'll happen is nightwing this
movie has been in development forever it
has had the same director attached for
as long as i can remember and i do
believe this is the thing that would
expand out the batman universe without
needing the batman i think you can much
easier make a nightwing movie without
batman than say a robin movie or even a
batgirl movie i think you can make a
nightwing movie and have dick grayson
fully formed and in bloodhaven give me
that nightwing movie next up we've got
static shock this is our 13th property
static shock has been in development for
a few years but got some heat at dc
fandom when it was confirmed they
announced a writer they announced a team
i keep hearing michael b jordan might be
involved as producer i can't get
confirmation on that but i do think this
is something that hbo max could use i
want it to be theatrical but i love that
90s animated series it's a comic book
that's really important it's a comic
book that addresses more street level
things it's a comic book that addresses
interpersonal relationships much like
spider-man does and i love the actual
character of static himself and i think
they could do some really cool things
playing with tone and i think it's a
really special property static shock is
a really cool character that has
electric-based powers but he uses them
in more ingenuity based ways so he's got
like a disc right and he can fly around
on it because of static electricity so
he wields it not like electro directly
he actually you know he can zap people
but he also uses it to fly he also uses
it to power certain things it's a really
almost stem based idea where it's using
electricity in inventive and
science-based ways instead of the more
traditional zap zap we've also got black
canary this has been development for
quite some time she is the on and off
again love interest of green arrow she's
a character that is very hard to
translate correctly but i think if you
do it right is a very empowering
character she is a fascinating take on a
lot of uh strong feminist ideals that i
think if they land will really empower a
lot of people and i think that her
costume is inherently empowering if you
do it right so as much as i want to see
a lot of these other characters i'd love
to see black canary handled deftly
because she's really funny she's really
intimidating at the right times in all
the right ways next up we have supergirl
speaking of characters i'd love to see
to get time to shine in a full
feature-length film this is a character
i've actually struggled with this is a
character who doesn't always work in the
comics for me this is a character that
when written poorly feels like hey what
if superman was a girl but when they
write her correctly she's the cousin of
kellell that has her own journey that's
been through her own struggles that has
a lot of different issues with her
powers that i personally recently love
the tom king run there's a supergirl
woman of tomorrow series that one that's
a great just title it's a play on man of
tomorrow but also like supergirl into
woman woman tomorrow her evolution her
journey from a supergirl to a superwoman
all of that's great but supergirl is a
character that is really hard to find
the pathos in that's really hard to find
the connection to if she's not written
well tom king's run connected me to her
in a way that i hadn't been before so i
highly recommend that run and i really
hope that the supergirl movie can feel
the same and i want little girls to have
a character to look up to i mean there's
so many beautiful female-led stories
i've already mentioned here but i really
want dc fans not just have wonder woman
i want little girls to not just have
these characters that they're like oh
this character feels like me and i think
supergirl can do that for a lot of
people we've also got the untitled man
of steel sequel i hope it exists i want
it
i need it
will it happen will henry cavill get to
put on the suit that he has in his
closet ever again i hope so this is low
on the list because i don't know if
it'll ever happen i want to believe
it'll happen it's the one i could use
the most give me man of steel too
henry cavill is superman let him fly
lobo i love i love the character lobo
number 17 lobo this man is dc's answer
to deadpool this man fights santa claus
this man has so many weird space hijinks
imagine a space pirate deadpool imagine
captain jack sparrow but he's jacked and
he talks like basically jason mamoa
would have been perfectly cast if he
wasn't aquaman i want that kind of rough
and tumble biker from space he's got a
giant space hog and flies around
thieving pillaging
he's an anti-hero that actually feels
like an anti-hero but he's written
really fun and like i said he fights
santa claus from time to time that's how
little beeps he gives i don't know if we
swear yet in koi's comic corner i
digress next up black hawk this is the
first of two that i don't think will
ever exist this was a movie that steven
spielberg was attached to i had the
middle section that was maybes with a
side of doubt now that we're past man of
steel stronger doubt next up we've got
one that was just canceled it could get
revived though since it was just
cancelled at the top of the discovery
merger depending how far along they were
i could see it coming back it is the
wonder twins movie the wonder twins are
an iconic duo from the super friends era
and you know the people that they do
like handsman they turn into ones water
ones an animal they're crazy but i think
it could work for a younger audience i
think depending on how well dc super
pets does i could see wonder twins being
revived and i do think we need to also
appeal to a younger audience joker very
dark and adult birds of prey very dark
and adult the batman very dark and adult
we do have shazam which is you know
about kids but there's crazy demons that
eat people and throw them out of
buildings i think there could be some
things that are geared towards towards
kids and i think wonder tone to be a
great one and finally my number 20 of
any dc character next to mr miracle
which i don't know if i'll ever get but
i really really wanted we were supposed
to get a property from avery to verne
and tom king but i really wanted to
happen i don't think it ever will called
new gods next to mr miracle the comic
character i want plastic man plastic man
officially as a writer i don't know if
that means development is further along
or if they've just accepted one of the
scripts but plastic man recently got
some movement and it is officially
technically on the dc slate and those
are 20 dc properties i hope we get and
this was hopefully under 20 minutes it
has been humbling to be here on rejects
channel without the og real rejects
because i'm considering myself one now i
just said oh geeks i'm the new blood
koi's comic's corner is because of folks
like you i got so many comments talking
about wanting me to have my own thing
here and then the first video did so
well i'm honored to be here with more
stuff this was a different format so if
you guys also like these mega lists
leave a comment below let me know it
works i also hope some of these comic
recommendations i gave you if you want
any of these characters specific comic
runs i couldn't i gave you 20. i
couldn't give you each one but if
there's anyone you specifically want to
know leave a comment if there's any
video you want from this list of 20
where i can extrapolate in the usual
format out let me know and if you want
any questions answered directly you can
find me on tik tok you can leave a
comment here below you can find me on
twitter hunt me down on the internet i
want to share my comic zeal with you and
that's we're doing right here i
appreciate y'all we'll see you next time
on koi's comic corner